The final answer we get when multiplying these complex numbers together is
negative 7 plus 22i. So how do we get this? Well, as before, we need to make
sure each term in the first set of parenthesis is multiplied by each term in the
second set of parenthesis. So we start with 4 and multiply it by 2. And then
also by 3i. And then we take 5i and multiply it by 2 and then by 3i as well.
Then we just need to simplify it within each of these terms over here, combine
like terms and come up with our final answer. I think the trickiest thing here
is thinking about these middle terms and thinking about the final term. We can
see here that multiplication involving imaginary numbers Works in pretty much
the same that working with real numbers and variables does. We have 4 times 3i,
the 4 multiplies the 3 to make 12. And then the i is still a factor,so it's
multiplied in as well. 5i times 3i is just 5 times 3 times i times i or 15 times
i squared, which is negative 1.